we had filmmaker ty West sitting on the
same couch and somewhere within the
interview or maybe the radio interview
he said home he could either do two
things for a job he could be a filmmaker
or he could be a busboy I love it what
is that for you what I mean you're just
now coming into this thing where you
feel like this is your calling yeah yeah
um I definitely have very few skills
that outside of filmmaking or working in
some capacity in the film industry
probably assistant like an assistant
like secretarial um you know running an
office but I can't stand that like an
office outside the film business I
probably couldn't stand on the office
and it's very hectic but yeah I have
very very few skills and they wouldn't
pay very well you know um and you know
just outside of the film business are
teaching English well you were a
journalist for a while yeah yeah was
that after the acting yeah that was
after the acting yeah I did freelance
journalism that was interesting getting
I did like more on like cultural topics
you know meeting different artists or
you know school like a community topics
like schools and districts and private
schools so I was like it was nice to
really get in-depth with people and get
to know a certain person I was
interviewing or a subject matter that
helped in other aspects of my writing
well you also mention too I think that
once you saw like cables on the ground
and it just reminded you of childhood
because you're just like I spent so much
time on the set so from that knowledge
having spent all this time on the set
sometimes you said even more so than
being at home what would you advise
other actors crew members aspiring
directors about handling themselves on
set despite being good and doing their
job as you mean as a director I'll
handling themselves on the side yeah
director and also with actors what are
some of the things that maybe people
don't know aside
knowing your lines and showing up on
time and things like that what are some
of the things that you've learned that
are outside of people's general duties
yeah but that are essential to getting
that next job yeah um well essential to
getting the next job I wouldn't that I
thought would be hard to comment on but
well actually that's not true um I think
like my parents definitely taught me
this and then I kind of learned this
myself being part of the crew if you're
in the higher up positions treat your
crew well because I've been treated
badly by higher-ups producers some
directors for sure um I guess that was
the only really two people that can
treat you a certain way on a step well
no that's not true but the crew if you
have a good relationship to the crew
which my mother always maintained she
was a production designer first and then
she transitioned producing but she was
always kinda even as a production sire
you are cruel even though your head your
head of a department you're still the
crew and so she because she came from
that and I grew up with her um I always
felt like I was part of the crew and my
father is really amazing with his crew
polite respectful thankful he doesn't
feel like I movie can get me without
them which we all need I mean that's
that's the truth um so and then setting
um I just recently saw an interview with
Oh Jeff Bridges was interviewed by a
documentarian that's making a
documentary about my dad and he was he
was asked about what it's like to be on
a SAT with Peter Bogdanovich and he said
he always makes it very peaceful and a
nice environment to be in okay and Jeff
was going on and on about this and how
important it is to set the the vibe I
guess you would say for the whole shoot
because people work their butts off and
the last thing my dad's not a screamer
unless you this is a thing he will
scream but it'll be under absolutely
cessary reason why he's screaming I've
only heard him do it like once or twice
and everybody kind of snapped to
attention because he doesn't do it and
I'm nobody felt abused because it was
for purpose you know okay um and a lot
of time somebody will yell off like a
like a really big mistake happens more
because of like you know but I my
father's just not like that so um that
creating that kind of environment and
when Jeff was talking about it I was
listening to the interview cuz I just
wanted to see Jeff so I came I was like
oh I did that same thing without
remembering exactly that that's what my
father does but I you know what thinking
back yes he did those are all I set that
like thanking the crew you know making
the actors feel comfortable between
setups or between takes hence when they
do their they do their take their
comfortable so I think that's that helps
because then you don't get reputation of
being you know horrible on setting a
screamer and difficult to work with like
I would never want anybody to say I was
difficult to work with I think I'm tough
and a bit hard worker but difficult to
work with would be I would hate to have
that for an actor what do you think some
of the things are that they should
remember aside from from the obvious
things but what are some of the unspoken
things that are you know maybe how to
treat crew or yeah i think they if they
don't they need to respect the crew and
thank them and maybe you know like I
heard that i think it was i think i
heard that Reese Witherspoon um got
massages for her whole crew was I think
that it was Reese huh um or something in
that being where she gave a gift to the
whole crew I mean that's amazing cause I
mean they're never gonna forget that
yeah um something like that you know if
you have the means to do something like
that if you don't if you're you know
you're a bit part or you know you don't
you just don't you can't do something
like that then um you know thanking them
or writing a note to somebody who did
something nice you know and then
listening to as an actor I think it's
really important to listen you listen to
your director listen to your other
actors I mean I learned that in acting
listening is like key and I think a lot
of actors who've trained would would say
of course that's obvious but being able
to like not just listen to the person
who's directing you but listen to the
rest of the crew be able to come on set
and feel the vibe and know like maybe go
up to somebody and say hey man how you
doing you know for a second my nose on
the way to the sack like you know so
your demeanor on set baby and ma be cut
off from everybody to maybe but does
some for some people that's a process
that they need to isolate you know
that's from that some people have that's
the way they work they're very intense
and I would respect an actor if that's
what he needed hmm you know so I
probably communicate with starting her I
probably communicate with the rest of my
crew if I was director and this was a
process for one of my actors and let's
say he had the lead or a very like maybe
he had a supporting role that was like
very intense I would at least
communicate with everybody look this is
his process this is what he needs don't
take it personally to the people that
need to know right now do you uh
communications key would you say you're
more introverted or extroverted Oh in
that sense because I think for a lot of
in Traverse they do need that internal
time to be with themselves where's
extroverts of course they feed off the
energy of other people yeah i mean i
would say as a director I was definitely
more it's hard to say I didn't socialize
I was really like when your director
there's so much stuff going on that you
don't really have time to socialize but
when I did I would definitely go out and
chat with people but I felt like you
know my time was limited as far as how
much free time I had
which completely different than when I
was crew you have a lot of downtime
sometimes just waiting not so much with
the gaffer's and electricians and the
grips but a little kind of a supporting
area there's supporting crew sometimes
has a lot of downtime um you don't have
a lot of that as a director unless this
setup stay less lighting takes a long
time you know but then you might be
rehearsing with your actors or you can
be busy but when i did have time i would
i would chat he would a little bit yeah
I wouldn't isolate right you know if I
need quiet time I would if I didn't have
a trailer but if I needed quiet time and
there was maybe an area of a room I
could go into I would do that but I
really need that